Okay. Um good morning. Today we do um
Sigma Freud. Uh first what I will do is
I will put Freud in the context of the
western religious intellectual and
literary tradition. All right. So in the
beginning um the main religion for us
humans during the um ice age was
animism.
Okay. And the idea of animism is that we
humans are no are no different from
every other living conscious being in
the world. Uh we are like the trees. We
are like the animals. We're all
interconnected together. And life is
just a cycle
um of life and death, birth and rebirth.
All right. And this is this religion is
still around today in many primitive
societies for example in the Amazon. And
then we transition to the mother
goddess. So as we became more
agricultural, fertility was more more
important. We need to have more children
and we needed to grow more crops. And so
we began to worship the mother goddess
and women were of very high status uh at
this stage in history. But as
populations grew and towns came into
being, they came into competition with
each other. They start to war against
each other and this created
polytheism. Polytheism is the idea that
each place has its own god. That's its
patron. And when these places come into
conflict and war, the way they settle
disputes is the losing party, their god
becomes servant to the winning god. And
this creates the idea of the pantheon
that we see in Greek Roman mythologies
as well as Norse mythologies. Now the
radical break from this tradition was
the birth of
montheism. Now um there's going to be a
lot of scholarly debate about which was
the first monotheistic religion. Some
say um there are certain Egyptian cults
that were monotheistic. Some say the
Jews were. Some say the Zoroastrians
were. in this class. Um, what you what
you learn is actually it was the
Christians who were the first true
monotheistic religion. And the reason
why is the Christians introduced the
idea of the Holy
Trinity. All right? Can remember what
the Holy Trinity is. The Holy Trinity.
The idea is
God,
Jesus, and the Holy
Spirit. These are
different
entities, but they are co-equal to each
other. They are separate but unified.
They are different but equal.
And this idea um it's very hard for us
to logically reconcile. The only way for
us to understand this is if God is both
nothing and everything. Therefore, it
excludes everything. There can be no
other God with our God. Okay? And this
is the idea of montheism.
And the power of montheism is that for
the first time in human history, it
creates the idea of the individual
because when God is
everything, you have a direct connection
with God and it removes you from the
community. Okay?
Now this will create a lot of problems
in the future. But at this point in
history, remember monotheism is being
promoted by the Roman Empire as a way to
consolidate its rule over its vast
territory. At this stage in history,
this is not a problem. And the reason
why is mediating you and God is the
Catholic
Church. But not only that, the Catholic
Church
mediates God for everyone. So in this
way the church create its own
community. Okay. So at this stage in
history this is not a problem. But
remember
um the church becomes corrupt and there
are many religious form reformers who
believe that you don't really need the
church in order to access God. In fact,
you have a moral imperative to access
God directly through the Bible. You have
to read the B Bible by yourself and you
have to interpret it properly. Okay? And
so obviously the most sim reformer is
Martin Luther. Now this is important
because what will happen is by limiting
the church you create direct direct
access to God and this creates the idea
of
crisis in faith.
The idea of crisis in faith
is how do you truly know as a person
whether or not you love God and how do
you know God loves you? Think about your
mother, right? You know your mother
loves you and you know you love your
mother, but there are many days when you
really hate your mother and you fight
with your
mother. Okay. So um it's hard for us not
to doubt ourselves. And so this creates
the crisis in faith because um in
Protestinism you are required to show
absolute faith and devotion in God. If
you doubt, if you hesitate, you will be
condemned to hell. Right? So this
creates idea of crisis in faith. Um
historically there have been many
solutions to this problem. different um
uh prophets have proposed different
solutions. So let's look at three
different solutions. All right. So the
first solution is the idea of
wealth accumulation. All right. So the
these are the Calvinists, right? They
argue that to show your true faith in
God and for you to prove to yourself God
truly loves
you, you make a lot of money. Right?
That is a testament to the power of your
faith, wealth accumulation. So that's
one solution. It's a very popular
solution. It's what gives us capitalism
today. The second solution is that if
jihad, you will die for your faith.
You'll sacrifice yourself to promote the
truth of God. Right? That's also a
solution. Um and then there's one more
solution that we will discuss today and
it's hard for us to truly understand. So
I'm I'm going to take some time to
explain it fully. Okay. This is the idea
of
transgression. So um let me explain it
to you slowly. The idea is this.
You must demonstrate complete and abute
faith in God to be one of the elect to
go to
heaven. To do so, you must demonstrate
courage. Um you must um demonstrate
fanaticism.
The best way to do that is to prove
yourself to God by rejecting the laws of
men, by rejecting human
morality, by
um rejecting social taboos, by breaking
social taboss as you demonstrate your
faith in God. Right? Now, I know this
sounds like a strange idea. Um but let
me give you an example to show you what
this means. Let's just say that in
school I decide to start a new class and
this new class is called individual
empowerment. And my very first
assignment to all my students is I want
you guys to go shoplift. I want you guys
to go steal a piece of candy from a
small
store. And of course you are disgusted
and you are appalled by this suggestion.
What if you get caught? Well, you might
get expelled from school. You might be
uh jailed. Your parents may punish you.
You may be outcast from
society. And then I tell you as and then
I tell you have faith.
Trust me, when you do this and you break
the social taboo that's preventing you
from real realizing your full potential,
you will feel an extreme sense of
exhilaration, liberation, excitement,
and this
will motivate you to do greater things
in life. By breaking taboos, by
transgression against society and
showing your true faith in
God, you will master your
destiny. Okay? And so you guys go and
you go steal something from the store.
You get away with it and guess what? You
feel excited. You feel exhilarated. You
feel energized. Okay? And that's the
idea of transgression. And um this has
always been a very uh um this and and
this has been around for us for like
hundreds of years as well. Okay. So
these are the three main ways that
historically
um the religious practitioners
practitioners practitioners have tried
to resolve the issue of the crisis of
faith right wealth accumulation that's
calminist jihad and but you you also
have transgression remember
transgression it's very important for
discussion okay so remember this idea
now um another way to resolve the crisis
in faith is through philosophy
epistemology
ology.
Epistemology. Epistemology is really
just means the theory of
knowledge. How do
ideas come together? What does knowledge
come from? How do we know what we know?
Right? Because the question of crisis of
faith is essentially how do we know? So,
epistemology is really um philosophy's
attempt to resolve this crisis in faith.
Remember before we discussed
Kant
and Kant proposed the idea of
active
subjectivity. Active subjectivity is the
idea that we are not just passive
uh consumers of information. We actively
participate in reality. We imagine
reality in a way that allows us to
understand
it. Um what Kant tells us
is we imagine space and time onto
reality which creates a world of
appearance for us to understand. The
problem with Kant
is what is reality and Kant doesn't
know. In fact, he tells us it is
impossible to truly understand reality.
And this creates a problem because if
that's the case, then how do we know if
reality exists or not? It's entirely
possible that we are in a computer
simulation, right?
So, so
Hegel comes along and resolves this
issue by introducing the idea of the
gist. Okay, the gist, the spirit, the
mind. He argues that this is the
manifestation of God that is the
underlying basis of all
reality. And from this reality comes the
material world.
What h what will then happen is that
markx will come along and he will argue
that guys is really
history. Hegel believes that the gist is
in a process of rec reconciling itself
with the world. It's becoming the world.
It's bringing us along with it so that
one day everyone will achieve full
enlightenment.
Markx inverts Hegel and puts the
material world before the world of ideas
and he argues that history it is a
movement of class
struggle and the end of history is when
all class struggle ceases and we all
become equal in a workers's
paradise. Why? Because as capitalism
becomes worse and worse, as the politer
increase in number but are exploited in
greater uh but but are
oppressed by the capitalists, eventually
the politer, you and me will develop
class consciousness and we will unite.
We will overthrow the capitalist class
through collective action.
Okay. So this is Markx. Now today we
will study Freud because what will
happen is Freud will come along and he
will present a completely different
conception of the movement of history
and of the individual. He
argues that the individual is really
just unconscious forces embedded within
the
brain. Okay. So these three forces are
superego, the
ego and the id. The ego is who we think
we are. The super ego are these social
forces that act upon us. And the id are
these hidden sexual urges. And what he
will argue is actually these hidden
sexual urges are the true foundations of
who we are as well as of civilization.
And he names two of them. Okay. The
first is what is called the
edypo the edypole complex.
And the second is electro
complex. So remember
that Edypuz is a character from Greek
mythology, a king who killed his father
and married his mother. Electra is also
a character from uh Greek mythology. Um
a woman who wanted to kill um her um
mother and marry his father. Okay. Uh,
Electra is from the Ishelis play the
Aristia. Um, Freud was remarkably well
read in Greek mythology as well as world
literature. So he argues these are the
two fundamental basis of who we are. If
you're a man, you are the edible
complex. If you have if you're a woman,
you are the you have the electro
complex. Okay. Now
um this is all strange
because Kant makes sense. Hegel makes
sense. Markx makes sense. They all seem
to flow from each other. And then you
have
Freud. Okay. So the question then is
where did he get this
idea? Where where's this from? How did
he develop this idea? All right. So, so,
so we'll look at this question in great
detail today. All right. So, at so um
everyone sort of knew that Freud's
theory of
unconscious is
problematic. Um, and he had a very
famous student, his best student, his
hair parent named Carl Young.
And Carl Young really saw Freud as a
father and he worshiped Freud and he
wanted to improve on Freud's theory of
the unconscious and over time what Carl
Young will do is he will systemize this
idea. Okay. So for Carl
Young we have the
ego and the
ego is made up of two forces. the
conscious
force and
the
subconscious. The subconscious is also
divided into the
personal as well as the
collective. Sorry, uh it's not
subconscious, it's unconscious. Okay,
unconscious. So the personal conscious
are just our our memories or
experiences. The collective
unconscious is the
collection of all society's memories and
experiences. Um, and they are captured
and expressed whenever we engage in
society, when we eat the food, when we
talk to people, when we watch movies,
when we read books. Okay, the collective
unconscious is embedded through society.
You breathe it like you would breathe
air.
Okay. So, um K uh sorry, Yun also says
that we have the
enemist and the
enema. In other words, we sorry, in
other
words, we are made up of two opposing
forces, the male and the female. There's
a duality to us.
Um
so when when we meet people the ego
projects a
persona. Okay the persona is just
basically our best self in a certain
social context. So so in school you're a
student and you try to be the best
student. At home you're a daughter. Um
at McDonald's you're a friend. Okay. So
so you are different personas in
different social contexts.
Now we try to protect our best self
but we are made up of a lot of bad
memories, bad thoughts. So the ego
suppresses
uh the worst aspects of us in a shadow
form. Okay. So the shadow is really the
alter ego of the ego and this Y argues
is what is called the
self. All
right. And what he tells us is life is a
constant process of self-discovery. If
you truly want to master yourself, you
must discover who you are. And that will
take a lifetime of um self-exloration
guided by a psychotherapist. All right?
And this sounds much more logical,
right? and it's become really the
standard model for modern day
psychology. Now, you would think that
Freud would be happy that Coyong came up
with this new idea on how to improve his
theory, but Freud
um was
infuriated that Yung would question his
theory. In fact, Freud was notorious for
being a control freak. He re he executed
Yun, refused to have any anything to do
with him. In fact, everyone in the
community around Freud
um would now distance distance
themselves from Cole Young and there
would be no reconciliation between the
two ever. And that's why and that's why
Co had to had to go and develop this
this
theory. Okay. So,
um and it's strange because all Cole
Young is trying to do is improve Freud.
So, that le that gives us the second
question. What why was Freud so afraid
of criticism? Why why was he so
secretive? All right. And then the third
question that we will look at today
is why did this idea become so popular?
In fact, the ideas of Freud and Cole Yun
will become the basis of a major
cultural movement called modernism.
And modernism is the cultural movement
that we still live in today. Now there
are many different definitions of
modernism but for us the easiest
definition
is
cult of the self.
We live in a world in a society in a
culture that's obsessed
with ourselves with self-improvement
with
self-empowerment. All right. So
um we will look at where this came from.
Okay. So the three questions we're
looking at today is first of all where
did Freud get this idea for the edible
complex? Second is why was Freud so
secretive? The third question is what
explains Freud's popularity? Why was he
why was he so influential and why was
his influence able to spread so quickly?
And what I will show you today
is Freud became so influential and so
famous not because his
psychoanalyst system was designed to
help his
patients. Ultimately, his system was
designed to pro protect the interests of
powerful interests, powerful men. Okay,
that's my argument to you uh
today. Okay. So, having made the general
argument, what I want to do now is look
at the evidence to support the argument.
Okay. So um again this is a chart that
summarizes the different perspectives of
these four major thinkers Kant Hegel
Marx and Freud. Okay so to summarize the
main ideas Freud believes that our
sexual urges is what underpins our
identity as well as civilization. It's
because we cannot control our sexual
urges that gives rise to religion which
helps us um cope with our guilt. Okay.
Um he also believes that truth lies and
our suppressed
memories and in his framework God has
abandoned us. There's really no God in
his system. We are left to fend for
ourselves. We are left to deal with the
trauma being alone. All right. So um
let's put Freud in his historical
context. So Freud lived and worked um at
the end of the 19th century primarily in
Vienna and at this time Europe was going
through fundamental, social, cultural,
economic, political change. Um we were
transitioning from the preodern era to
the modern era. Before we lived
primarily in towns and villages where we
dealt with each other
emotionally and we had a purpose in our
community but when we moved to the
cities
um it is money and the clock that
regulates our life and it's still true
today. Right? So um when you come to
school
um what controls your behavior it's the
it's it's your grades as well as the
clock right if you are late for class if
you're not if you're absent then you are
then your grades get deducted right so
it's the same concept as we have today
all right um now because of these social
changes in two new fields sociology and
psychology are developed in order to try
to um understand what these changes mean
for us as humans. So in the field of
sociology there are three major thinkers
pioneers of this time Max Weber, Eml
Durkham and this man George Siml and
George Siml wrote a wonderful
essay called the metropolis and mental
life in which he describes what the
impact of moving to the city has on
people. Okay, so we'll just read a
couple
sentences. Instead of reacting
emotionally, the metropolitan type
reacts primarily in a rational manner,
thus creating a mental predominance
through the intensification of
consciousness which in turn is caused by
it. Thus, the reaction of the
metropolitan person to those events is
moved to a sphere of mental activity
which is least sensitive and which is
furthest removed from the depths of the
personality. Okay, so let's use a
metaphor. Let's think about food. When
you're in the village, you grow your own
food and then you make the food, you eat
it, and that's it. Okay? You know
exactly where the food comes from. You
know how it's made and you're not really
curious about the food. But the one
wonderful thing about the city is you
get um exposed to all different types of
cuisine, all different types of flavors,
and that excites your imagination.
You're much more curious about it,
right? You're you want to know where
this food is is made. The problem though
of course is this is all an abstraction.
You have absolutely no idea where the
food comes from. You have absolutely no
idea how where the food is made and
quite honestly you don't even know the
food is healthy for you or not. Okay.
So, so um the city life is a higher
abstraction and of course today we have
the internet which is even a higher
abstraction. Okay. So you go from the
village to the city now to the internet.
Um, of course, this creates a lot of
problems for people because this
transition causes psychological issues
and the three major psychological issues
are enemy. Okay? Um, and what this means
is before the village, you know exactly
what to do. Um, but you you move to a
city there are different rules and it
confuses you. For example, in the
village, if someone punches you, you
punch back and then afterwards you
become friends. In a city, if someone
punches you and you punch back, you both
go to jail. So, it's confusing for
people. Okay. Uh, alienation means that
you have actually no freedom in the
city. You work from 9 to5, you get up,
you get up at 6:00 in the morning, get
on at 7:00, then get to work at 9:00.
Then you get up for work at 5 and get
home at 10:00. Okay? So, everyday is the
same reg same regulated life. And it's
and it's um and you lack freedom. Okay?
Okay, that that causes alienation. The
last idea is disenchantment where you
feel as though you are just a machine
and you have lost human agency. Okay, so
this creates lots of psychological
issues and that's why at this time psych
psychology is becoming much more
popular. Um this is Simon Freud and um
he was a very ambitious
uh medical student who became a
psychologist and he start to see
patients and these patients were often
young women who were historical
historical is not a word we use anymore
but back then it just meant that they
couldn't control their emotions. Um,
they were prone to outbursts, crying.
When they saw a man, when they were
touched by a man, they screamed, they
cried. They couldn't form healthy
relationships. Okay? And so Freud was
tasked with figuring out why this was
happening and trying to help these
women. And he spent a lot of time with
these women. And he did something pretty
novel at the time which is he basic he
just won their trust and asked them
directly why are you like this and the
woman um after many sessions after
becoming friends with Freud they start
to confide in Freud and they told him
the truth which is I'm hysterical I'm
afraid of men touching me because when I
was
young my father abused
me and Freud at first was shocked. I
think everyone would be shocked. But
over
time he would hear this story from so
many different patients with the same
symptoms that he concluded that they
must be telling him the truth. And he
wrote a very famous paper in 1896 called
the ideology of hysteria. Ignies means
origins. Okay. And in it he says, "My
previously communicated assumption that
trauma, specifically sexual trauma,
cannot be stressed enough as a pathic
agent, was confirmed a new. Even
children of respected, high-minded
parental families fall victim to real
rape much more frequently than one had
dared to suspect. Either the parents
themselves seek substitution for their
lack of satisfaction in this
pathological manner or else trusted
person such as relatives
um abuse the ignorance and innocence of
children. Okay. So he's arguing that
abuse is much more common than we are
led to believe. Even those that we think
are pillars of society engage in the
sort of abuse. So what he's doing is
that he's becoming an advocate for
advocate for these women. He's telling
the world they're not crazy. They're not
being hysterical. They were traumatized
and that's why they're behaving like
this. If you got hit by a
car, your leg wouldn't um you wouldn't
be able to walk. Well, these women are
the same way. They were traumatized
physically when they were young and
that's why they are behaving like this.
That's why they have problems forming
these emotional bonds of others.
Um the symptoms of hysteria are
determined by certain experiences of the
patients which have operated in a
traumatic fashion and which are being
reproduced in a psychological life in
the form of pneummetic symbols. Okay. So
what he's saying is this is not made up
in the mind. This happened physically
and then it gets represented in the
mind.
Um so that's Freud arguing for
um his patients. Now let me introduce
you to a man named Jeffrey Mason and he
wrote a book called the assault on
truth. His story is this. He went to
Harvard and he became very interested in
psychoanalysis and he studied began to
study it and he became friends with Anna
Freud who is Simon Freud's daughter.
Anna Freud um thought very highly of him
and um she trusted him with the letters
of Sigman Freud and before this was this
was not open to the public and no one
knew about these letters but Jeffrey
Mason spent years going over the letters
and what he discovered shocked him. The
early Freud and the later Freud are two
different people. They have two
different theories about trauma and
abuse. Okay. And in his book, he
presents the evidence which are Freud's
letters to friends. All right. So, let's
just read a couple. This is early Freud.
I therefore put forward thesis that at
the bottom of every case of hysteria,
there are one or more occurrences of
premature experience, occurrences which
belong to the earliest years of
childhood. Okay.
There are a whole number of other things
that vouch for the reality of infatile
sexual scenes. In the first place,
there's a uniformity which exhibit in
certain details. So, what he's saying is
um I know that people don't believe me,
but the evidence is clear. I've talked
to different people. They don't know
each other. They're telling the same
story. They're bringing the same
details. So, either there's this giant
conspiracy or they're telling the truth.
It is less easy to refute the idea that
the doctor forces reminiscences of this
sort on the patient, that he influences
him by suggesting to imagine and
reproduce them. Nevertheless, it appears
to me equally untenable. I've never yet
succeeded in forcing on a patient a
scene I was expecting to find in such a
way that he seemed to be living through
it with all the appropriate feelings.
Perhaps others may be more successful in
this. When you read Freud, you see him
as a very clear, as a very nuanced, as a
very balanced thinker. Okay? He accepts
there are different possibilities. It's
possible that he himself is suggesting
false memories to his
patients. And he and he and he says this
this is possible, but I have failed to
achieve this goal. And there are others
who may be better at this than I, but I
haven't been able to do it. Okay. So
based on this evidence um he argues that
these patients must be telling truth.
Okay. This is the early
Freud. Um this is Sandor for the longest
time they were colleagues. They were
best friends. They were both advocates
for
patients and then um they had a falling
out. Okay. they started to
um they they basically refused to talk
to each other anymore. Okay. And the
reason why is Senator Frenzy continue to
advocate for
um patient rights whereas Simon Freud
completely changed his attitude. All
right. So let's look at the new Freud.
Since child masturbation is such a
general occurrence and is at the same
time so poorly remembered, it must have
an equivalent in psychic life and in
fact it is found in the fantasy
encountered in most female patients.
Namely that the father seduced her in
childhood. This is a later reworking
which is designed to cover up the
recolleation of infatile sexual activity
represents an excuse
and thereof. The grin of truth contained
in this fantasy lies in the fact that
the father by way of his innocent
caresses in earlier childhood has
actually awakened the little girl's
sexuality. It is these same affectionate
fathers that are the ones who then
endeavor to break the child of the habit
of masturbation. Okay. So what Freud is
trying to say is young girls from a very
early age they are sexual animals. They
have these urges and they have this
longing for the father. And it's
compounded by the fact that the father
in his innocence hugs and caresses his
little girl. It's made worse when the
father notices that the girl is
masturbating and tries to stop her. And
this creates a sense of both resentment,
hatred, and more longing. Okay. So now
what Freud is saying
is it's not the father. The father did
nothing. He's innocent. The girl is the
one who who who because of these sexual
urges has all these sexual fantasies
that she is no longer able to
differentiate between fantasy and
reality. All
right. So um this is from from the essay
fragments of analysis of hysteria. The
love hungry little girl, unhappy at
having to share her parents' affection
with her brothers and sisters, realizes
that all that tenderness comes flowing
back when her parents are made anxious
by her illness. The little the girl now
knows a way of calling forth her
parents' love. So now he's explaining
why hysteria is so common in society.
And the answer is very simple. Women are
desperate for attention. It's that
simple. They're fine. They have no
issues. They just want attention. And
that's why they are hysterical, okay?
Because they know that illness attracts
attention from caregiving
uh
males. Um this is this is Simon Freud's
book, Civilization in Its Discontents.
And in it, he expresses his contempt for
women in society. All right, let's read
it. Furthermore, women should soon come
into opposition to civilization and
display their retarding and restraining
influence. Those very women who in the
beginning laid the foundations of
civilization for the claims of their
love. Women represent the interests of
the family and of sexual life. The work
of civilization has become increasingly
the business of men. It confronts them
them with ever more difficult tasks and
compels them to carry out instinctual
sublimations of which women are little
capable. All right. So Freud's saying
this, we must thank women because
without women there being no
civilization. They give birth. They
raise
families. But men are smarter than
women. And so men are tasked with the
responsibility of building civilization,
of creating science, of creating
literature, of creating philosophy, of
politics, of administration.
Okay. And but what all women want is
attention to be doted on. And that's why
women hate civilization. First of all,
because they're not smart and they can't
really uh contribute to civilization,
but also because it takes uh men away
from from them. Okay. So now the
question then is okay. This is like
really strange because the four that we
encountered earlier was
a
scientist. Um, very clear, very nuanced,
very subtle in his thinking. This
Freud, he's like a mythmaker. He's
almost like a priest. Okay. So, so what
explains the trans transition? Okay.
Well, there's there's a very simple
explanation, right? Um the simple
explanation which is simple explanation
is
um he may be treating his patients who
are a young woman but who's paying the
bills? The father, right? It's a father
who's paying Freud. So um if Freud went
to the father and said, "Oh, I talked to
your daughter. It's your fault that
she's like this." Well, they wouldn't be
very happy. Okay. So, um, we can
understand why at the end of the day,
Freud decided that he needed to change
his story if he wanted to maintain his
clientele. Um, so the question then is,
okay, is there evidence to suggest that
sexual trauma and abuse was common in
Vienna at this time in history, the late
19th century? And the answer is yes.
There is some piece of evidence, okay?
not complete. Okay. But there's some
piece of evidence suggests this was
actually a thing in Vienna in the late
19th century. So um this is so Vienna is
part of the AustriaHungary Empire and
there are lots of secret societies and
religious cults at this time. Okay. One
of them is called Frankenism and
Frankenism
uh um rejected Jewish norms and he and
believe they were obligated to
transgress moral boundaries. Okay,
remember the crisis of faith, right? How
do you demonstrate um your faith in God?
How do you know God loves you? How do
you know you're faithful? Well, you
break taboos. And they were breaking a
lot of taboos. The fragrance engaged in
sexually promiscuous rights such as the
infamous 1756 incident where they were
allegedly caught dancing around a half
naked woman. Um at its height,
fragmentism claimed perhaps 50,000
followers. That's a lot. 50,000
followers is a lot. And a lot of them
were powerful people. um primarily Jews
living in the Polish Lutheran
Commonwealth as well as central and
eastern Europe. Later Francis were
encouraged to convert in in mass to
Catholicism. Okay. And um so who are
these people? Well, they are followers
of a man named Sibetai Zevi who lived in
19th century who who was a um Jewish
rabbi who lived in 19th century Ottoman
Empire. And for many he was extremely
charismatic and he was basically their
messiah. Okay, he was the Jewish Messiah
and he preached a religion of
transgression because transgression
meant courage. It meant empowerment
u it meant true faith and he had a lot
of followers and that's why the sultan
called him and then said okay I'll give
you a choice you can either continue
doing what you do and I'll kill you or
you convert to Islam. so he can murder
Islam. But when he did so, he told his
followers, I did so because God doesn't
care about what you do. God cares about
what's in your heart. As long as you're
true to God, what you do in life does
not matter. Okay? And the religion he
started is still around
uh today. Okay? And um this is from
Wikipedia. Okay? All this is from Wik
Wikipedia and you can look look you can
look at it online to make sure that I'm
just making making this up. All right.
So as part of this movement
um I mean you can read this right? All
right. Um sexual abuse was actually
pretty
common. So we have evidence suggests
that yes um these women were probably
telling the truth and Freud knew knew
so. But Freud ultimately had to change
his story in order to prot protect his
livelihood. Okay. But there's also
another reason why Freud had to change
his story. Okay. And this it has to do
with a man named Ignis
Simise. Ignis Simise lived in 1840s uh
Vienna. He was and he he was a doctor
who worked at uh Vienna General Hospital
and he was in charge of two maternity
clinics, places where women gave birth.
um same hospital, same staff, but the
maternity but the mortality rate at the
second clinic was much higher than the
first clinic. Women would uh could could
die giving birth because of fever. So
10% of of women were dying in the second
clinic and only about 3% were dying in
the first clinic. So in wise he was
appalled by by this and so he launched
an investigation as to what was
happening and he spent seven months a
long long time trying to figure out what
happened what was happening and he
looked at all different possibilities
including weather including um treatment
including personnel everything okay and
then he had a radical breakthrough he
had an insight which is this in a second
clinic it was a teaching hospital. So
doctors would in the morning work work
with cadaavvers, okay? They would show
students how to how to dissect dissect
cadaavvers and then in the afternoon
they'd go and deliver babies. And
similar he didn't know why because at
this time germs were not a thing. People
didn't know know about the existence of
germs. Um he didn't know why but he he
theorized that there could be
connection. So he created a protocol. He
basically had everyone wash their hands
uh using a um a formula of um
water, chlorine, and lime. And we still
use it today. Exactly the same formula
today. And so he tried this protocol and
it was a miracle because because after
people start to wash their hands, no one
died in childirth anymore. And similar
wise being a rigorous scientist he
collected all this data conducted a lot
of experiments to prove this had to be
true that washing your hands could save
lives. And then we presented his
findings to the staff the doctors of
Vienna General Hospital believing that
they would um they would praise him and
then promote this all throughout Europe
in order to save as many lives as
possible. Instead the doctors told him
they had to um they had to keep this
quiet. um they'll promote similice uh
they respect him and he did amazing work
but if word came out that uh this was
true then people would know that they
were responsible for the deaths of these
women before and their reputation would
be in tatters um and then sim of course
responded by yes I understand that but
if we don't publish our findings if we
don't let the world know know about this
more women are going to die in child
birth and they fought for a long time,
years and years and then eventually
similar wise he was black uh
blacklisted. He would he would not he
was not allowed to work work ever in
hospital again and then ultimately he
was confined to an incident asylum where
he was killed by the guards and he let
and he died leaving a young family and
so that's what happens to you when you
defy powerful people in Vienna uh in the
19th century and Freud didn't want the
same fate okay and he al he also had a
young family um so this story is
horrible but if if you don't believe me
you can go on Wikipedia Okay. Um he was
institutionized in in the same asylum
um by his colleagues and in asylum he
was beaten by the guards. He died 14
days later. All right. So this is a fate
that will happen to you in Vienna if you
defy powerful people. So So now we have
an explanation for why Freud made the
transition, why he changed his story.
But now there's another problem which is
how does Freud convince his patients to
go along
right before he told his patients I
believe you um and they trusted him and
now he's changing his story. So how can
he convince them that they in fact do
suffer from sexual
fantasies and like these this experience
of sex sexual abuse it's all just made
up in the head and that's a very hard
job to do. So the solution
is the interpretation of dreams. All
right. So Freud pioneered a new way of
hypnotizing
um his
patients. So together they would analyze
their dreams, right? Because if you if
you talk about their memories in their
past, they're going to fight back and
says, "I remember very clearly." you
talk about your dreams that allows you
to
um suggest
subtly new ideas and new memories to
basically implant uh new memories
and basically gaslight that person.
Okay, does that make sense? All right,
so the interpretation of dreams. So um
that is the story of Freud.
Okay, but this leaves a question is why
did this spread throughout the world?
All right, and that's something that we
will look at in part
three. So a lot of the influence of
Freud has to do with Carl Young who will
take his ideas of the unconscious and
systemize it for popular um consumption.
Okay. Um so we already discussed his
framework where we are all dualities.
Okay, we have an ego but we also have a
shadow. We have a conscious but also a
unconscious, a personal as well as
collective, an animous and an
animma. Um yung popularized ideas of
personality types, right? Introvert um
extrovert which is what we still use
today. All right. Um the main influence
is in
modernism a transformative art movement
beginning around the um early 20th
century. All right. So arguably the
first great
modern artist is James Joyce who in
1922 published
Ulyses. Um James Joyce was Irish. He was
an Irish expatriate and he actually
studied Dante in university. So um he
wrote Ulyses um as a way to imitate
almost surpass
Dante. And of course Ulisses refers to
Homer's
Odyssey. Now um we're going to read a
passage from Ulyses to understand
um the P's writing. Okay. In evil
modality of the visible at least that if
no more thought through my eyes
signatures of all things I'm here to
read sea spawn and sea rack the nearing
tide that rusty boot star green blue
silver rust colored signs limits of the
dian fun but he adds in bodies. Okay. Um
what does this mean? I have no
idea. All right. I I have no idea. Um I
can explain to you Dante. I can explain
to you Homer and Shakespeare, but I
struggle with James Joyce. And there are
two reasons why. Okay, the first reason
is he was um a singer. So you have to
read what he writes as though it's
music. Okay, it's meant to be read read
out loud. So it's musical and that's
really the power of his writing. He's
more focusing on the style rather than
the substance. Okay, that's the first
thing. Second thing is that he was
extremely well read and everything that
he writes in every sentence there are
multiple illusions and references to
other books. Okay? So you must have read
what he read. You must have experienced
what he experienced in order to
understand him. And there are those who
argue that Ulisses is the greatest book
in the world. In fact, if you go online,
you just Google the best book ever
written in human history, James Choice
is up there. Okay. Uh, Ulissiz is either
number one or number two on these list
of 50 best books in human
history. Um,
um, and there is there are many who tell
me, "Yeah, James Joyce is hard, but if
you spend the time to go over what he's
writing and connect the references, you
will have a transformative intellectual
experience." Okay? It's almost like
doing a jigsaw puzzle. Um, and that's
all true, okay? But think about what
they're saying. They're saying what
they're really saying is that James
Joyce believes that he is God. He has
the mind of God. And if you spend the
time to understand what he writes, and
it might take you years, decades, okay,
you will access the mind of God. That's
very different from Dante which is
trying to use poetry to bring people
into the mind of God which is the truth
of the world. Okay. Donis is a lot more
accessible than James Joyce. So look
let's look at the differences. Uh modern
literature as represented by Ulyses it
is elitist. It's self self-reerential.
Okay, it just has a lot of illusions and
references, but you don't you actually
don't know what the meaning is like what
is the bigger story here and it's
usually something called stream of
consciousness writing which is it's
trying to capture the mind as it thinks
and works. Okay, that's different from a
from Homer who was who was very
democratic. He was trying to bring
beauty and truth to the people through
epic poetry. Okay. So starting with
modern literature, we have this abrupt
change in the nature of literature.
Before it was about empowering
people to seek the truth for themselves.
Now modern literature, it's really just
this very elite club of very arrogant,
hotty people. Okay.
Um James Joyce was good friends Virginia
Wolf. In fact, Virginia Wolf actually
published um James Joyce in
1927. Wolf published a book called To
the Lighthouse and it's probably her
most famous work and um in it she's also
trying to respond to Joyce to the
Lighthouse. It's very much based on
Homer's Odyssey and um it's it's a very
it's extremely well written. Okay, let's
let's just look at what she writes.
There were the eternal problems,
suffering, death, the poor. There was
always a woman dying of cancer even
here. And yet she had said to all these
children, "You shall go through with
it." To a people she had said
relentlessly to that and the bill for
the greenhouse would be 50 pounds. Okay.
So what she's what she's doing is she's
reading a book and she's thinking about
the issues raised by book. But she's
also thinking about life like, "Oh, I I
have to go and do something." Okay. And
that's really how our minds work. So
this captures really well stream of
conscious thinking and she's heavily
influenced by Freud, right? She's trying
to go into the unconscious and trying to
figure out how the conscious unconscious
works. The lighthouse is really about
memory, about perception, about
remembering. All right. Um, but again,
it's extremely
self-indulgent and it's inwardlooking
and it's very and again it's a radical
departure from traditional literature.
So, let's compare
um modern literature with Dossi. Mr.
Before we discuss
Dossi for DSvski the heart it's a deep
impenetrable ocean and our psychology
responds to external events. We live in
the world and respond to the world. We
must surrender ourselves to others to
seek salvation and redemption. We cannot
rely our on ourselves to forgive
ourselves to love ourselves. We must
rely on others. We are we are in a
community of people. Okay. So these are
the truths of doski. When we get to
modern literature, self-discovery will
allow for selfmastery. Our psych
psychology responds to suppressed
memories. We can be our own salvation
and redemption. It's too
optimistic. Uh it's too positive. Okay?
It's saying that hey, if you're poor,
um don't worry about it. As long as you
think happy thoughts, you'll be good.
Okay? this this idea of positive
psychology right that we have
today.
Um Cole Young and Fred also had a major
influence on Pablo Picasso and you can
see it from his painting um head of a
woman. Okay. Now what you will notice is
it's it's it's a cubis portrait of a
woman but if you look further it's
actually two people as well. Okay. And
so what this is doing is it's visually
representing the theory of the self as
presented
by Yung. Okay. So so do do you see the
similarities?
Great.
Okay. So why is this art spreading
throughout the world? Well, I mean not
to be conspiracy theorists, but let's
look at an article, right? Was modern
art really a CIA scop? All right. So
this article is from JStore which is a
academic journal very mainstream and
this let's read what it writes in the
mid- 20th century modern art and design
represented the liberalism individualism
dynamic activity and creative risk risk
possible in a free society. Okay. So in
other words right now
uh the capitalist west is at war with
communism. 1920s, 1930s, 1940s, commis
is spreading all around the world, it's
very popular among people. It calls for
collective
action. So, um, the capitalist west, the
powers that be, they're spreading Freud,
they're spreading joy, they're spreading
wolf, they're spreading public, they're
spreading all this art, this modernist
art in order to create a cult of self.
Because if you believe in the cult of
the self, if you believe that you are
the source of everything, then you don't
you're not capable of collective action.
Okay, so in many ways this this is
response to the problem posed by
communism. And this will be um obviously
uh most obvious during the cold war.
Okay, does that make
sense? All right. So why would that be
bad? Why would the cold itself be bad?
Well, this is Macau Buchanan and he
explains it very well in his writings.
Okay, so let's read really quickly what
he
wrote. Having human in man and freedom
above all is a product of a social
collective labor. To be free and
absolute isolation is an absurdity
invented by theologians, metaphysicians
who have replaced the society of humans
by that of God, their phantom. to say
that each person feels free in the
presence of God that is the presence of
absolute emptiness
nothingness. Freedom in isolation then
is a freedom of nothingness or indeed
the nothingness of freedom slavery. God
the figment of God has been historically
the moral source or rather the immoral
source of all slaveries. So what he's
saying is the radical turning point in
human history is the invention of
Christianity because it allows it gives
us the idea of
individualism. And we think that's a
good thing because we we're taught that
individuality individ individualism
means free choice. It means freedom.
What he's saying is that's that's an
absurdity. We only have freedom from our
community. We only have freedom if
others are free around us. If we are
free but no one else is free then we are
slaves as well. So
because individuality prevents us from
working with others from loving
others then that makes us slaves to
ourselves and that allows for the powers
that be in society to better control us.
Okay. And so what he's saying is
Christianity is a slave religion. All
right. Right? It was designed to make us
all into slaves. And this will and he
and Buchanan lived in 19th
century. But if he read
Freud, then he would also argue that the
cult of psychoanalysis, it's really
about entrapping yourself in your own
emotions. As for us, we want neither
phantoms nor nothingness, but living
human reality. And we recognize that man
can feel free be free and therefore can
achieve freedom. In order to be free I
need to see myself surrounded by men by
free men and be recognized as such by
them. I am free only when my
individuality reflected in the mirror of
the equally free consciousness of every
individual around me comes back to me
strengthened by everyone's recognition.
Okay. So what he's saying is this. If
you want to be happy, if you want to be
free, care about others, be kind to
others, work with other people,
sacrifice your own self-interest for the
self-interest, for for the for the
greater good. Okay, that is what that
will that is that is what will make you
really happy. And that's generally true
because think about this, okay? If
you're by yourself, will you be happy?
Probably not. But if you have a family,
you have kids, you don't have any
freedom, but you're a happier person in
many in in many many ways. You're a more
free person because you have better
control of your emotions. You have more
purpose in life. All right. So,
um let's bring this to the present day.
Social media. What social media is? It
is the democratization of the cult of
itself. Before only the wealthy could
enjoy the cult, right? only the wealthy
could take the time to self-indulge. But
now with social media, everyone can
participate in the cult of self and that
has led to a global
um epidemic of depression. Okay. So look
look at year 2015. You see this huge
spike in depressive symptoms because
2015 is the year when we had access to
smartphones, right? So now young people
feel they can't do anything right. Life
is not useful and I do not enjoy life.
Okay. This huge spike which has led to a
huge spike in suicide. All right. And
this is happening throughout the world
not only in North America and Europe but
also in Latin America and East Asia as
well. So the color itself which
originated in Europe has now conquered
the world through
technology. All
right. So,
um that's it. All right. So, the answer
to the three questions. The first
question is where did Freud get his
idea? Second question, uh why did Freud
break of Yun? The third question, why is
Freud's idea so popular today? Okay.
Well, it's all to serve the interests of
the powerful and that's the world we
live in today. And the only solution
moving forward is if we rediscovered our
humanity. We if we are able to find the
courage to um care about others and put
the interests of others before our own
interests, we ourselves must choose to
kill the cult of the self. Okay. All
right. So, uh next class we will do um
nationalism, right?